No one expected the final trailer for the
Harry Potter prequel Fantastic Beasts: The
Crimes of Grindelwald to tell them anything
they didn't already know from watching previously
released teasers and TV spots.
But when Warner Bros. dropped the last piece
of promotional footage on September 25, minds
were blown.
Why?
Because it features a brief clip of a woman
named Nagini turning into a snake.
And that has opened a huge can of worms for
Harry Potter fans, leading Harry Potter author
J.K.
Rowling to issue a public defense of the film.
In the original Harry Potter series, Nagini
was a gigantic sinister snake who served as
the evil lord Voldemort's companion and assistant,
while also acting as a Horcrux, one of the
vessels for a portion of Voldemort's soul.
Nagini was eventually slain by Neville Longbottom,
opening the way for Voldemort's final defeat.
So the revelation that Nagini was once a human
woman that can turn into a snake - or possibly
a snake that turns into a woman - is definitely
a shocker for fans.
But the surprise hasn't been all that welcomed
by everyone.
Both longtime and casual fans of the franchise
have a number of concerns, perhaps most importantly
over the choice to cast South Korean actress
- and Marvel Universe veteran - Claudia Kim
in the role.
Twitter user Jen Moulton started the firestorm
when she tagged Rowling in tweet that read
in part,
"Listen [...] we get it, you didn't include
enough representation when you wrote the books.
But suddenly making Nagini into a Korean woman
is garbage.
Representation as an afterthought for more
woke points is not good representation."
Other Twitter users piled on, with one decrying
the decision to cast one of the two actors
of color in the Fantastic Beasts franchise
as a, quote,
"literal object owned by a white man inspired
by Nazis."
And others voiced concerns that the casting
choice bore echoes of old stereotypes, such
as those associating Asian people with snakes,
as well as the Dragon Lady cliché.
Rowling didn't take the criticism lying down,
responding to the original attack with a tweet
that said,
"The Naga are snake-like mythical creatures
of Indonesian mythology, hence the name 'Nagini,'
They are sometimes depicted as winged, sometimes
as half-human, half-snake.
Indonesia comprises a few hundred ethnic groups,
including Javanese, Chinese and Betawi.
Have a lovely day."
She later added that she has been holding
onto the secret of Nagini's true nature for
"around twenty years."
That revelation seemed to actually spark even
more anger from another subsection of fans
who complain about Rowling's history of revealing
- or changing - details of the Harry Potter
universe years after the series wrapped up.
Most famously, three months after the final
book came out in 2007, she announced that
Dumbledore was gay, and had been in love with
Grindlewald.
Many applauded Rowling for the announcement,
but some felt she was trying to have her cake
and eat it too by pandering to LGBTQ fans
without truly taking the perceived risk of
actually portraying Dumbledore as gay in either
the books or films.
The Dumbledore controversy gained new energy
in January 2018, when director David Yates
revealed that Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes
of Grindelwald won't make it "explicitly"
clear that Dumbledore, played by Jude Law,
is gay - despite the purported love of his
life being at the center of the sequel's story.
Instead, there seem to be just vague hints
for hardcore Harry Potter fans to decipher.
"Dumbledore why can't you go?"
"I can't move against Grindelwald.
It has to be you."
The Nagini and Dumbledore controversies are
just the latest PR hits for Fantastic Beasts:
The Crimes of Grindelwald, which has faced
intense scrutiny from the moment it was revealed
in November, 2017 that Johnny Depp was set
to return to the role of Grindelwald from
2016's Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find
Them despite highly publicized allegations
that he had assaulted his ex-wife Amber Heard
prior to their divorce.
It remains to be seen whether any of these
controversies will affect how Fantastic Beasts:
The Crimes of Grindelwald performs at the
box office when it arrives in theaters on
November 16, 2018, but one thing is for sure:
even if the film isn't a must-watch for everyone,
J.K.
Rowling's twitter feed definitely is.